unsere parteien setzen im wahlkampf
ansonsten immer mehr auf ein thema das
wissen sie sicherheit härtere strafen
für verbrecher fordern fast alle großen
parteien sehr gut
umso erstaunlicher wenn man mal
recherchiert stellt man das fest dass
deutschland im jahr 2017 gleichzeitig
ein regelrechtes masia paradies ist es
tatsache mafiosi kommen hier zu uns nach
deutschland mit koffern voller geld und
freuen sich über ziemlich perfekte
arbeitsbedingungen die vorteile die
deutschland bietet sind dass es keine
kontrolle und kann hart mafia bekämpfung
gibt wenn man es so wenig geldwäsche
bekleide ermittelt niemand und niemand
stört mich so lange ich in deutschland
eine steuerzahler werde ich in ruhe
gelassen
ja es wird immer du kannst in
deutschland drogen geld waschen so viel
du willst aber wehe deine stolz währung
kommt einen tag nach dem 31 befunden
willkommen in deutschland
italiens polizei ist tatsächlich
stinksauer die beschweren sich immer
wieder bei offiziellen stellen in berlin
weil wir so wenig machen gegen die
italienische mafia bei uns nicht mehr
strafbar mitglied bei denen zu sein weil
sie können jeden verein zahlen auf
machen das sei vollkommen okay ja weiß
ich wenn sie das interessiert das wäre
das mafia starterpaket das starter kit
da kriegt man erstmal ein
mitgliedsausweis von der mafia einen
folgekosten 500 euro schein
und natürlich einen abgeschnittenen
daumen das ist klar der unterschied ist
in italien gilt die beweislastumkehr das
heißt der gangster muss beweisen dass
sein geld legal ist sonst nimmt man es
ihn wieder weg durchs geldwäsche
paradies deutschland fließen jedes jahr
unmengen masia schwarz-gelb herrenlos
einsam er gott da muss man doch was tun
liebe zuschauer das deutsche geldwäsche
hilfswerk bittet um ihre mittel
übernehmen sie noch heute eine
patenschaft für unschuldig nach
deutschland geratenes schwarzgeld dieses
geld hat schlimme dinge gesehen
also geben sie sich einen ruck und
helfen sie geld aus kriminellen
verhältnisse zurück in die legalität
werden sie bitte heute noch schwarzgeld
taten beim deutschen geldwäsche
hilfswerk das gute gefühl etwas
schlechtes getan zu haben ein angebot
das man einfach nicht ablehnen kann
ja
[Musik]
das entspricht nicht das entspricht
nicht unserem selbstbild aber
deutschland ist ein mafia paradies in
ganz europa setzt die mafia so schätzt
man jedes jahr 100 milliarden euro um
jedes jahr 100 milliarden genauso viel
wie bmw muss die macher natürlich viel
besser für die umwelt
die mafiosi kaufen ohne ende immobilien
in köln im ruhrgebiet und besonders
gerne in erfurt jetzt könnt jetzt da
sticht man schon nicht mehr von mafiosi
sondern von máriássy optimale
investitionsbedingungen